wir sind heute auf einer Dachterrasse in
Berlin Charlottenburg und diese
Dachterrasse gehört Peter schöatur
vielen Dank für die Einladung dass wir
uns heute hier unterhalten hat einen
ganz besonderen Grund sie feiern ihren
90 Geburtstag herzlichen Glückwunsch
danke schön was bedeutet das für sie 90
Jahre nichts Besonderes muss ich ehrlich
sagen ich habe nie gedacht dass ich 90
Jahre alt würde z nächste Mal und ich
halte von Geburtstagen überhaupt nichts
an Astrologie glaube ich nicht also
insofern ich freue mich darüber dass so
viele Leute daran teilnehmen und dass
auch der frag das feiert aber ansonsten
mich persönlichüht es nicht sie haben
eine Wohnung hier in Berlin eine Wohnung
am Rhein in der Nähe von Bonn eine
weitere Wohnung in Paris und eine in der
Nähe von Nizza gibt's für Sie so etwas
wie Heimat haben sie ein zuuh Hause ja
Moment
ichm Kol hat mal von mir gesagt ich se
ein luthering das heißt das war dieses
Zwischenreich nach der Aufteilung des
kolinger Reiches zwischen Deutschland
und Frankreich genau das nicht und im
Grunde fühle ich mich da zu Hause ich
fühle mich in Deutschland zu Hause fühle
mich aber auch in Frankreich zu Hause
jetzt sind wir ja heute hier in Berlin
viele Leute sagen Berlin ist derzeit die
faszinierendste Stadt Europas kriegen
sie davon was mit sind sie auch so
fasziniert von Berlin gut es passiert
sehr viel ich weiß auch dass Berliner
unges renom hat aber es ist wohl doch
eine Stadt für junge Leute als
für für Leute meines Alters nicht ist H
können das sag ich gehe nicht in die
Discos
abends wenn ich mich hier auf der
Terrasse umschaue dann machen die
Gegenstände einen sehr exotischen
Eindruck z.B diese Figur hier woher
stammt das das habe ich absichtlich
getan ich habe mein mein schön des
Lebens habe ich in Südostasien verbracht
das besten Erinnerung und ich habe mir
so eine kleine indochinesische Ecke
hingestellt bzw meine Frau hat es
[Musik]
ausgebaut sie haben uns erlaubt dass wir
uns hier ein bisschen umschauen was mir
besonders gefallen hat ist der Name für
diese
Fotowand ja meine Freundin das in
hausaltarwas eine Anspielung auf meine
alterkeit aber sind eben Episoden aus
meinem beruflichen Leben und zwar sehr
einprcksam muss ich ehrlich sagen mit
chin das da ist mit Amerikaner in
zentralvetnam die uniformlichter Trage
ist übgens meine alte französische
mituniform und das da ist mit den
Afghanen von Hm unterwegs und hier das
der Ayat romeini aufgenommen übrigens am
Tag nach der Besitzung der
amerikanischen Botschaft das H W ich am
meisten hänge muss ich sagen we für mich
ein ein Kes Abenteuer war al
1951 Jahre alt und das war das letzte
Stück von Französisch Indus China was
noch an der chinesischen Grenze klebte
jensits davon war noch Partisan von
chankek und die volksfungs war 30 km
entfernt und ich habe dem Ober Kost mit
dem ich war der Waffen transportiert für
die changck Leute habe ich gesagt kann
ich mal rüber Reiten zu den
Nationalisten wie sich n im Grunde war
OP und ich bin dann mit einem Pfer ist
kein Maul wie manche sagen rüber
gerittenen und auf dem Rückritt Ware ich
diese jungen tha Mädchen das ist
gebirgstei sind das die waren dabei
Blumen zu zu zu pfücken und ganz spontan
haben s das Pferd angehalt das Pferd
besteckt mich besteckt und ich hatte
einen Teil partisanche dabei und habe
mach do mal ein B ich habe nie gesagt
dass aus dem Bild was würde das ist eben
D geworden und das ist für mich eines
der schönsten erleebnisse meines Lebens
gewesen im Prinzip sehr romantische
Erinnerungen an indchina das war so ein
Stück kiling nicht das war also noch die
alte große Kolonialzeit und wie gesagt
die
Rotchinesen haben daraufhin reagiert der
sind dann anschließend über die Grenze
gekommen und haben also auch das Gebiet
von functto aus der französischen seit
auch besetzt am 90 Geburtstag darf ich
das fragen wie geht es ihn
gesundheitlich ich kann wirklich nicht
klagen ich bin ganz gut drauf machen Sie
noch täglich Kniebeugen und Situps ja so
ein bisschen nicht also das ist ich
übertreibe das auch nicht we man muss
nicht meinen dass man das
Leben auf ewig verlängern kann indem man
ein paar übung macht aber ich versuche
einmaßen fü zu bleiben und V allem auch
weiterhin meine Reisetätigkeit auchrech
zu halten das ist ein schönes Stichwort
denn wer denkt 90 Jahre das ist für sie
kein Grund zu Hause sitzen zu bleiben
erst vor wenigen Wochen waren sie wieder
einmal im Libanon daraus ist auch ein
eine sehr schöne Reportage geworden und
daraus schauen wir uns jetzt ein paar
Ausschnitte an unterwegs in
Beirut Peter schollatur recherchiert für
ein neues Buch im Libanon herrscht große
Anspannung längst ist das Land in den
Syrienkonflikt einbezogen islamische
Gruppen bekämpfen sich mit Terror ein
neuer Bürgerkrieg droht im Norden hat er
schon begonnen
[Musik]
seit fast 7 Jahrzehnten ist scholatour
als Journalist auf der Suche nach
Erkenntnis und nach dem großen
Erlebnis immer noch und immer wieder
will er mit eigenen Augen sehen und dann
analysieren bei Rut im Jahr 2014 steht
vielleicht wieder vor einem
Krieg 15 Jahre von 1975 bis 1990 dauerte
der letzte Bürgerkrieg scholatur war
damals oft vor Ort es war hoch spannend
und vor allem
man war natürlich auch hier war die die
Frontlinie zwischen den ist islamischen
Kräften oder nzaristischen Kräften
immerinand auch den Palästinenser die
die große Rolle im Bürgerkrieg gespielt
haben und den Christen der
maronitischen katib das war die vier
ungefähr und die frontlins überschreiten
war immer ein erhebliches Risiko
gewesen wenn sie unterwegs auf Reisen
sind gibt's da für sie eine Grenze wo
sie sagen nee das mute ich mir mit
meinen 90 Jahren nicht mehr zu nein es
gibt eine andere Grenze dann wenn die
Situation völllich unberechenbar ist
also wenn ich in Afghanistan war mit den
mahiden die damals gegen die Russen
gekämpft haben war ich in totaler
Sicherheit also da konnte mir nichts
passieren ich mein leibwchter der hat
sich für mich tochießen lassen im Irak
nicht mit den schietischen Brigaden war
auch absolute Sicherheit
auf jetzt in Syrien ist ein derartes
Durcheinander an kampfhaufen an
Extremisten auch an
Mördern dass man sich sag den Leuten
nicht mehr antrauen wde ich bin ein paar
Kilometer drin gewesen D mich je
Offizier der Freien Syrischen Arme das
sind ja die relativ ordentlichen
Leute gehen sie
aus derjene der ihn anbietet zur Führung
der gegenseit zu kommen der wird sie
dann den verkaufen und sie wden un g
festken dann dann mache ich Stopp also
sie kalkulieren schon ganz genau welches
Risiko gehe ich ein und welches nicht
ich habe immer die Risiken kalkuliert
und es ist Gott se Dank auch nie einer
zu Schaden gekommen das größte
Kompliment was mir kamer Leute gemacht
haben war mit Ihnen gehen wir da rein
mit jemand anderen wür wir nicht da
reinehen planen Sie schon die nächste
Reise
ja und zwar jetzt in 10 Tagen ungefähr
werde ich nach Jamina fliegen das kenn
wenigstens fr V die hastadt von Chat ist
genau das auf der halben Strecke
zwischen Dakara K wde im Westen und
dibuti und dem Ausgang des roten mes
belband auf der anderen Seite und im GR
die strategische Position im Moment über
die aber keiner sprcht wie das ja immer
üblich ist die wirklichen Brennpunkte
werden im erst zu spät erkannt ich würde
mich mit Ihnen gerne ausführlich über
ihre Biografie unterhalten aber zunächst
interessiert mich doch noch ihre
Einschätzung der aktuellen Situation in
der Ukraine wie wie beurteilen sie da
die Situation ja man got man hatte gar
nicht so Kenntnis genommen dass die
Ukraine kein geeintes Land ist ich es
gibt den westlichen Teil der
österreichisch war bisschen zwischen den
Kriegen auch polnisch und der auch
äh katholisch orthodox ist also ist sie
haben den orthodoxen den byzantinischen
Ritus aber sind dem Papst unterstellt
das macht ein enorm Unterschied zwischen
dem Osten der rein russisch tieforthodox
ist auch die kusaken zu sagen haben und
wenn es eine Lösung für die Ukraine
geben sollte wäre es im Grunde ein ein
Föderation
eine Gruppierung
föderierte Gebiete die aber doch
sorgfältig vinander getrennt sind in
Kiev schaut do keiner durch da wird auf
dem AL da manifestiert und auf der Krim
ist ziemlich eindeutig die Krim ist
überwiegend russisch Putin russland hat
die Macht auf der Krim übernommen wird
Putin sich damit zufrieden geben oder
marschiert er am Ende auch noch im Ost
und Süden der Ukraine ein
Nein putin ist ja ein Mann des
Geheimdienstes er weiß wie weit er gehen
kann er verseht es auch seine Karten
auszuspielen das hat er jetzt in Syrien
gezeigt
und dass
er die wieder die oberhohheit Kontrolle
über die Krim haben will verstehe ich
durchaus abgesehen davon ich war was was
soll das hier dieses ewige polemisieren
gegen Putin wen will man denn an die
Stelle setzen
ich Russland ist immer autokratisch
regiert worden und wenn wir heute Peter
den großen bewundern der wirklich eine
absolut merkungte Persönlichkeit war
zart war der nicht ja der sie haben
Putin persönlich kennengelernt was haben
Sie denn für einen Eindruck von ihm
gewonnen ja man merkt eben schon seine
Vergangenheit als Geheimdienstoffizier
an aber er ist höflich er ist gut
informiert und beantwortet alle Fragen
sie haben 2006 also vor 8 Jahren eine
Dokumentation gedreht unter dem Titel
Russland im Zangengriff da schildern sie
wie Russland sich eingekreist und
bedroht sieht und warum die Ukraine so
unverzichtbar ist für Russland und da
wollen wir uns mal kurz ihre
Einschätzung von damals anschauen man
versetze sich in die Lage der russischen
Patrioten die NATO dehnt ihren
militärischen Einfluss über die
willfährige Ukraine bis zum Don
aus in Fernost blickt Moskau voll Sorge
aus seine menschenleere igerregion und
die boomende Großmacht China jenseits
des
Amur dazu kommt innerhalb der eigenen
Grenzen ein muslimischer
Bevölkerungsanteil von 20 Millionen der
seine Identität im koranischen Glauben
sucht für Wladimir Putin ist der Abfall
der Ukraine schwer
[Musik]
erträglich jeder erinnert sich an die
stürmische Begeisterung der Orange
Revolution auf den maan von Kiev die dem
Separatismus zum Sieg
ver dieser
nationalukrainischen Volkserhebung an
ihrer Spitze Präsident Victor juschenko
haben seitdem ihr Prestige
eingebüst Gegengewicht und Kontrast zu
Kiev bildet im Osten der Ukraine das
Industrierevier donbas mit der Stadt
donetk die einmal Stalino
hieß in diese Landschaft von Stahlwerken
und Zechen ist die Erinnerung an den
Großen Vaterländischen Krieg längst
nicht verblasst die Masse der
Bevölkerung bekennt sich zur russischen
Nationalität nach dem Verlust der
Ukraine sei Russland dazu verurteilt ein
überwiegend asiatisches Imperium zu
werden so verlocken bereits einige
einflussreiche Ideologen in Washington
und viele Europäer schließen sich diesem
neuen Drang nach Osten der NATO an aber
zumindest die deutschen müssten wissen
dass nur 300 km von dieser Grenze des
donbas entfernt eine Stadt liegt die
Stalingrad hieß und noch einmal 100 km
nach Osten beginnt das Territorium der
zentralasiatischen und überwiegend
muslimischen Republik Kasachstan man
muss das noch mal sagen diese Analyse
ist 8 Jahre alt stammt von 2006 aber die
gilt eins zu ein noch heute das ist mir
meistens in meinem Leben passiert ohne
Eitelkeit aber in dem Falle von Europa
muss man wirklich sagen die Europäer
müssen im Moment darauf bedacht sein
ihre Kräfte zu konzentrieren und nicht
zu expandieren schon Rumänien und
Bulgarien warahrschein schon zu viel
jetzt diese riesige Ukraine noch dazu
wäre völliger unsin und amerikanische
Staatssekretärin gesagt hat [__] die euu
äh hat im Grunde einen
äh vernünftigen lex entsprochen sowieso
bitte das für uns auch klingt die die
Russen sind ja in Sorge dass das was der
Westen hier in der Ukraine macht keine
selbstlose Unterstützung einer
Freiheitsbewegung ist sondern in
Wirklichkeit Teil einer Strategie der
NATO der USA der EU die Grenzen der NATO
bis nach Georgien bis in die Ukraine
auszudehnen und am Ende Russland in die
Knie zu zwingen ist da was dran an
dieser Furcht der Russen da ist zweifl
was dran ich sag nicht dass alle diese
me Meinung verzen es gibt auch in
Washington hochintelligente Leute aber
im Moment sieht es wirklich so aus als
se man darauf aus die Russen
zurückzudringen man spielt Kalter Krieg
auf einmal redet von Sanktionen was für
Europäer völlig blödsinnig ist wir
würden mehr unter disuntionen leiden als
als die Russen es ist also wirklich ein
ein Spiel im Gang was gar so groteskes
und diese ständige Putin Bäch auch ein
Steiner BCH sch gegen China auch zu fel
gegen Iran was hat uns Iran getan Z auch
zum f die Europäer verschätzen sich
völlig in ihrer Rolle sie sind keine
weltmach wir und haben in der Welt
nichts mehr zu sagen aber was bedeutet
denn das dann konkret sollen wir einfach
zuschauen wenn Putin da mit seiner Armee
in der Ukraine schaltet und
waltet schaltet ja nicht und waltet die
Ukraine ist zum großen Teil russisch
nicht dann soll man eben die Spaltung
machen und eine Trennung machen und eine
Föderation machen was was auch immer
aber jedenfalls man muss ja nicht die
die Russen der Ukraine zwingen
auf ihre Sprache zu verzichten was man
ja verlangt hat und im Übrigen müssen
wir eins Bedenken die Gefahren für uns
die liegen ganz wo anders die Liegen am
Mittelmeer aber das Mittelmeer haben die
Deutschen zwar für für Ihren Urlaub
entdeckt aber politisch ist das offenbar
in den Vorstellungen Berlins und
Brüssels völlig ab welche Gefahren sehen
sie
da wir haben in in Syrien
die Übernahme der Gewalt wenn Assad
stürzt was ja viele Leute auf erhoffen
und auf sehen dass sie dann alqida an
der Macht haben in Syrien und nicht in
Syrien in im Irak auch und im Libanon
zwangsläufig dann auch es seit den die
hisbullah die eine gute Truppe ist ich
kenne e man ebenfalls völlig verleumdet
und dann
eben dieses ständige
wie soll ich sagen pöbeln gegen den Iran
der Iran hat uns doch nichts getan das
wä für unseren fabelhafter
wirtschaftlicher Partner und ob du nun
eine Atombombe bauen oder nicht pakistan
hat eine Atombombe und die ist
wahrscheinlich sehr viel bedenklicher
als alles was die Iraner eines Tages
konstruieren werden also sie haben jetzt
geschildert welches
bedrohungsszenarioarium da existiert in
der islamischen Welt das würde ich gerne
ein bisschen später aufgreifen weil ich
möchte zunächst mal einfach den 90
Geburtstag zum Anlass nehmen und mit
ihnen ein bisschen mal in die
Vergangenheit in ihre Biografie zurück
bicken sie haben mal gesagt diese diese
Abenteuerlust diese Freude daran immer
hinauszureisen in die Welt die stammt
von ihrem Vater die hat ihr Vater bei
Ihnen eingeplanzt wie war das ja das war
im Grunde eine ich als Kind habe ich
sehr viel gelesen ich hatte mit 10
Jahren schon alle K maisis gelesen mein
Vater gesagt Zeit dass du auch was
richichtes liest und dass mir dann eben
Stanley magelan und kamch und so die
großen Entdecker gezeigt das hat mich
fasziniert und im Grunde wenn ich eine
freie Berufswahl GEW gehabt hätte den
Beruf gibt's ja nicht mehr wäre der das
eines Entdeckers gewesen und zwar
ethnologisch
kulturell religiös auch das hätte mich
wirklich interessiert und da hab ich
habe n das Glück gehab dass der
Journalismus mir die Chance dazu geboten
hat in einem Maße wie ich es nie hätte
er hoffen können und das internationale
war ja auch schon in ihrem Elternhaus
angelegt die Mutter stammte aus dem
Elsas ihr Vater Arzt war in lotringen
aufgewachsen also das zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich dieser
Grenzgänger war von Anfang an bei ihnen
angelegt ja wobei mir das
deutschfanzösische W ist im Moment große
Sorgen bereitet
denn Gott se Dank haben wir jetzt Seen
neuen Außenminister hern steinweierer
der vernünftig ist
aber auch Franz er Seite ist eben die
Position wahnsinnig schwach geworden wir
denken dass Frankreich von der gol auf
all heruntergekommen ist Frankreich der
kranke Mann Europas ist das übertrieben
oder ist das so ist Frankreich so
schwach Frankreich ist im Grunde ein
gesundes starkes Land was aber schlecht
regiert ist und was eben eine völlige
Revision seiner internen Strukturen
vornehmen z machen
das ist sehr reiches Land man Beziehung
reicher als Deutschland aber es ist
sagen wir jeder die wirkliche Dynamik
der Wille der willlle zur Macht der
gedacht so der ist da gekommen ich würde
gerne noch ein bisschen in ihrer Jugend
bleiben ihre Mutter war katholisch aber
stammte aus einer jüdischen Familie wie
sind Sie denn erzogen worden katholisch
jüdisch oder hat man ihn katholisch bis
in die Puppen nicht ich katholischen
Internat was von den jesen gegründet war
in der französischen Schweiz durch den
Alen Petrus carnesius und katholischer
kann man gar nicht erzogen werden sie
haben mal gesagt da habe ich den
Fundamentalismus kennengelernt in diesem
katholischen Internat das hat mir im
Grunde mein Verständnis für den Islam
erleichtert denn es gibt gewisse
Parallelen zwischen dem katholischen
Fundamentalismus so wie existiert
inzwischen mit franziskus lässt das
alles nach aber wie damals noch
existierte wo wir in unseren Liedern
noch nach der Inquisition riefen
ungefähr und
dem dem Islam der auch glaubt im Besitz
der alleinselig maenden Wahrheit zu sein
welche Rolle spielt diese katholische
Religion für sie in ihrem Leben eine
sehr große nämlich die katholische
Kirche hat mich geschützt äh und äh äh
ich habe die besten Erfahrung gemacht
also ich habe im Internat in den ich
gewesen in langen Jahr gewesen bin diese
ganzen unerfreuichen Dinge von dem
überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen gab's bei
uns gar nicht und vor allem habe ich
erlebt dass die katholische Kirche auch
in Deutschland zwar gerade in den
unteren räen die einzige wirkliche
organisierte Widerstandskraft gegen die
Nazis gewesen
ist ihre Eltern haben sie bewusst in die
Schweiz ins Internat geschickt wegen
ihrer jüdischen Herkunft weil das war
einfach gefährlich dann mussten sie
allerdings Anfang der 40er Jahre wieder
zurück nach Deutschland weil die Eltern
das Schulgeld nicht mehr überweisen
durfte und am Ende des Krieges haben sie
den Naziterror noch ganz persönlich
erlebt sie sind in Gestapohaft gekommen
wie kan das später später ich bin erstm
al in ein Gymnasium ein Schule in Kassel
gekommen und hatte dort wars Glück hat
ein Schuldirektor dann fabl auf der wann
war der war Partei genos das war damals
natürlich aber
mein persönlicher Status was ich war
wusste kein Mensch so dass ich völlig
umgestellt hat gelt und im
Grunde Zeit verbracht ich habe auch
keine Demütigung K dann nachher als K
kritisch wurde und die Fron sich nähert
dem besten dann habe ich versucht durch
die Front zu kommen im Westen das ist
gescheitert in Metzen dann am Mosel aber
dann habe ich nachher in jugosl das die
letzte Schwelle noch bei den dort
Partisan unter geschnappt worden und
dann habe ich
den Abgrund
des Daseins kennengelernt in den
Gefängnissen gesto die ging noch aber
das SD des Sicherheitsdienstes und das
das klingt blöd wenn ich das sage aber
das war für mich ein Stahlbad für den
Rest meines Lebens was schimes konnte
nicht passieren und ich habe das mit
großer Gelassenheit überwunden ich habe
auch keine traumat bewarttig ich träume
nie davon das was haben sie da erlebt
wie was haben sie da erlebt in der SD
ich habe einal an der schießungsmauer
gestanden eine scheinerschießung sicher
das
war und und wie kommt das dass Sie da
sagen ich habe das mit Gelassenheit
genommen also ja ich habe manche Leute
meinen dass ich Gemüt W
[Musik]
W fischerhund habe aber ich ich bin eben
nicht sehr sensibel und
gewis Robustheit auch nicht die Tatsache
dass ich ein Jahr nachdem ich in der
gestaphaft war und am Ende noch
flecktüfes hatte dass ich ein Jahr
später schon in indosina einem
fallschirmkommando eingesetzt war zeugt
für eine gewisse robotzeit ja sie haben
sich sofort nach dem Krieg bei der
französischen Armee gemeldet haben sie
nicht so ein so ein Gefühl gehabt
Schluss mit Krieg nach so einem
entsetzlichen
Weltkrieg für mich war ind China vor
allem ein exotisches Abenteuer und ich
wollte ja die Welt sehen und das wars
die anzige Möglichkeit was sollte ich
dann hier in diesem zerschossenen
kaputten in sich zerissen in Deutschland
sitzen und ich wollte auch nicht meine
wie soll ich sagen Nachteile die ich mE
nazisitten als Vorwand nehmen um mir
dann Privilegien zu eraschen und so nee
da bin ich schon lieber nach Indochina
gegangen sie haben sogar einmal gesagt
Indochina war ein erotisches Abenteuer
durchaus
durchaus das haben alle so empfunden die
dort waren die die ganze französische
die leben ja alle nicht mehr ich bin ich
habe euch Anfrage die französische
Botschaft bekommen über wir jemand ein
Buch über meinen
Kommandeur schreiben und sagt wir suchen
nach Augen es gibt nur noch einen aus
der Einheit erlebt das das ist ja schon
Natur also das ist alles
soll ich sagen das gehört aus der
Vergangenheit aber
ich habe das den Indochinakrieg als ein
großes romantisches Abenteuer auch
erotisches Abenteuer von Vietnamesen
sehr schöne Frauen das gesagt
und ich habe ja nach den amerikanischen
Krieg auch noch mitgemacht ich habe von
Anfang bis Z Ende
und das war für mich im Grunde die
schönsten Jahre meines Lebens zwischen
dieser Zeit als sie bei den
fallschönjägern in Frankreich waren 45
bis 47 und dem Vietnamkrieg das darf man
nicht vergessen das sind 20 Jahre
dazwischen Mitte der 60er bis Mitte 70er
Jahre dauerte der Vietnamkrieg das ist
das wo sie die meisten Zuschauer in
Erinnerung haben Peter schullatur das
ist der Mann der uns den Vietnamkrieg
erklärt hat in vielen vielen Reportagen
in seinen Büchern z.B der Tod im
reichfeld sie waren einer der ersten der
gesagt hat dieser Krieg der Amerikaner
in Vietnam ist falsch wann haben Sie das
erkannt das ist falsch was die
Amerikaner machen sehr früh sehr früh
und ich war der einzig der das gesagt
hat ich habe genauso wie in Afghanistan
ich war Afghanistan hätte man von Anfang
an wissen müssen dass es Sache schief
geht ich verstehe die Militärs nicht die
das gegen der glaubten nationbilding
betreiben zu können schon aber was nun
indina betriff ich kann es und sag die
Sache geht wahrscheinlich schief und
dann hat es das einzig mal ungefähr in
meinem Leben eine ein Inter ein
zensurversuch gegeben das auswteamt das
war damals der Außenminister Gerhard
schder nicht der Kanzler aus liest bei
meim inaten vorspr sagt halt den sch
doch ein bisschen zurück die Amerikaner
betrachten das als feinig wen das sagt
und S und me der Intendant Klaus von
Bismark
eichenlauträger an der ostfrand hat sich
dann zwei Stunden lang mit mir
unterhalten und dann hat er kurzen
prusisch gesagt machen sie weiter und
ich habe das gleiche Glück gehab ich
habe später auch noch Schwierigkeiten
gehab ichf war habe ich mit Dieter
Stolte das gleiche Glück gehab Stol hat
immer voll vor gestanden es gab so etwas
wie einen dramatischen Höhepunkt ihrer
berichterstatterzeit aus dem
Vietnamkrieg das war im Sommer
1973 da gerieten sie und ihr Team in die
Gefangenschaft des Viet Kong natürlich
entstand auch daraus wieder eine
Reportage die wir uns jetzt in
Ausschnitten anschauen können
etwa 30 km waren wir von unserem
Waldlager aus nach Norden gefahren in
Richtung anlock Motorfahrzeuge waren uns
nicht begegnet lediglich Fahrräder die
berühmten Transportmittel von Jen bienfu
auf denen die Partisanen bis zu 500 Kil
Last vor sich
herchieben Mina war in den ersten Tagen
der großen kommunistischen Offensive des
Jahres 1972 überrollt worden etwa 750
Einwohner sindur ben die weder flüchten
noch zwangsevakuiert werden konnten und
fast ein Jahr lang den amerikanischen
Bombenangriffen ausgesetzt
waren vor einer Bambushütte die speziell
für uns errichtet war wurden wir von den
Kaders der Befreiungsarmee offiziell
begrüßt informationsoffizier majoretung
erkundigte sich zunächst im Namen der
provisorischen
Revolutionsregierung nach unserem
Gesundheitszustand
ang die in unsem seor
befliche sagte major vietrung wir
möchten Sie als Freunde aus dem Ausland
aus Europa
[Musik]
empfangen wie kam es denn dazu dass sie
in die Gefangenschaft der Wirt Kong
geraten
sind das war eine Zwischenphase war K
hatte ja damals diesen seltsamen
waffenst abgeschlossen der praktisch den
Untergang Südvietnams beinhaltet das
darfich keine Illusion drüber machen und
niemand wusste genau wo die
Nordvietnamesen waren im Grunde schon
noch vietnamesische Regimente wo die
standen das wollte ich ja rausfahren und
bin also mit dem kameradteam und ü am
französischen K von der agence fr press
herausgefallen woll am nach wieder in
seigern sein und sind aber durch die
Sperren die normalerweise aufen die
haben uns wohl für C Leute gehalten die
südetnam haben uns durchfahren lassen
und plötzlich stand ich vem Schild mit
den an Zeichen der nationalen
befreiungswand des viedkong und ich habe
gesagt Kinder wendet die Autos ich mache
schnell ein Statement und Verfahren so
und da raschelte es im gschen dann kamen
die kleinen grünen Männer raus und ich
verstehe ganz gut mit mit Leuten
umzugehen dies Situation ich habe erstm
die Hand gegeben und als sie dann unsere
Kamera verchlagt abten unds dafür eine
Empfangsbescheinigung gaben da wusste
ich dass uns nicht allzu schlimmes
passieren würde die haben sich dann
erkundigt haben dann erfahren dass er
eben nicht urspr angenommen CIA Agenten
waren wirklich schon alles im Prinzip
herrschte ja in diesem Film das haben
wir gesehen ein eine ganz eigentümliche
fast fast freundschaftliche Atmosphäre
wie kam das ja das kam nachdem sie eben
die hatten ihre Verbindungsleute in
seigon zwar sehr intensiv nachdem Sie
wusen dass wir wirklich Journalisten
waren und meine Berichterstattung ist ja
auch beobachtet worden ich war ja auch
im amerikanischen Vietnamkrieg immer
sehr objektiv gewesen und hab diesen
ganzen Zirkus von bodyount
und endlosen Siege derfach nicht
mitgemacht und hatte da eben ein
gewisses R das ist mir immer wieder
zustande gekommen dass ich mit dem was
man früh die Eingeborene nannte gut
umzustehen wie haben Sie denn die die
Soldaten des wir Kong kennengelernt was
was waren das für Leute was haben die
für für Überzeugungen gehabt das waren
fabelhafte Krieger nicht war die hatten
ja
die waren ausgesetzt den Bombardierung
der
B52
bombenppichchen das waren Leute die dann
sich in Löcher gegraben haben um den
Widerstand zu leisten das war eine eine
fabelhafte Armee enttäuscht war ich
nachher nur nach der Machtergreifung
Hanus alsoimin in in seigon dass sie
sich an den sü
namesen gerecht haben bzw sich sehr
kleinlich Verhalten sehr lange gedauert
haben bis eine nationale Versöhnung
zustande kam sie haben vorhin
geschildert wie die Amerikaner beim WDR
Intendanten interveniert haben beim
Außenministerien und über das
Außenministerium dann dann bei dem WDR
gegen ihne ihre Berichterstattung weil
manche gerade aus Amerika gesagt haben
diese Berichterstattung ist
antiamerikanisch hat sie dieser Vorwurf
getroffen oder wie sehen Sie wenn Schau
gewesen wä hät sie das als einen
freundschaftlichen guten Ratschlag
empfunden genauso wie ich im den
Amerikanern auch in Syrien gesagt habe
Kinder l die Pfoten davon und vom Irak
das gleiche wo übrigens Bundeskanzler
Schuder die richtige Reaktion gehabt hat
und machen machen die Amerikaner denn im
Prinzip immer den selben Fehler von von
Vietnam über Afghanistan bis hin zu Irak
ist eine erschreck Schauspiel und auch
ein betrübes Schauspiel ich mag ja die
Amerikaner meine Schwester ist
amerikaneran gewesen äh aber und mit W
man Soldaten vem in Vietnam war hatte
man sehr kameradschaftliches
brüderliches Verhältnis aber äh die
Amerikaner haben seit ihrem grandiosen
Sieg von 1945 wo sie sowohl das Dritte
Reich niedergeworfen hab die Land in
Normandie war eine logistische
großleistung und die Japaner auch
besiegt haben
und also wirklich die als die Weltmacht
von da ab haben sie keinen Krieg mehr
gewonnen schon
Korea war eine Pat Situation nicht die
chinesis V tun die kaum bewaffnet war
die Volksrepublik existierte Z Jahre
haben die Amerikaner zurückgeworfen und
dann kam Vietnam und dann kam
Afghanistan dann
kam zweimal Irak und so weiter es geht
alles schief es ist aber das trifft
nicht nur die Amerikaner das trifft and
auch die Bundeswehr käme auch nicht
zurecht mit dem was man den
asymmetrischen Krieg nennt oder die
Counter insurgency und so weiter das
sind Dinge und da muss ich lich sagen da
habe ich eben sehr viel gelernt in
meiner Kommandoeinheit been Franzosen am
Anfang ich habe mir über diese Art der
Kriegführung nie Illusionen gemacht und
habe die von der Picker auf gelernt
Indochina das war ein großer Teil ihrer
Berichterstattung einen mindestens
ebenso großen Raum hat die arabische
Welt der Islam äh eingenommen sie haben
Mitte der 50er Jahre 2 Jahre in Beirut
arabisch studiert zunächst mal wie kam
sie auf so eine exotische Idee a Gott
ich äh ich war damals Journalist bei der
sabrücker Zeitung ich hatte zwar so
einen Bauchladen von verschiedenen
anderen Zeitungen die Haupt reien aber
das war natürlich keine dauerposition
und ich wollte dann einfach mein
Horizont erweitern bin dann da war ein
sehr
wie soll ich sagen qualifiziertes
französische sprach und Studieninstitut
auch für den Islam und das habe ich
zufällig kennengelernt und habe mich da
eins schreiben lassen und habe das eben
gemacht und es hilft dann doch sehr wie
man dann den Muslimen entgegenitt nicht
schon ein bism rahmanahim gibt einem
eine gewisse Sicherheit und wenn ich an
das Grab der großen schitischen Heiligen
wollte we sonst hinen kann dann ST dann
Muller und sagte VAT die erste so das G
D ich auch sagen kann D komm rein also
diese diese Kenntnis des Islam der
arabischen Sprache hat ihnen einfach die
Tür geöffnet zu vielen islamischen
Führern einer davon kein arabischer aber
ein iranische Führer war Ayatollah
komeni den haben sie sogar begleitet bei
seiner triumphalen Rückkehr aus dem Exil
in Paris nach Teran
1979 war das
Sadek got Sadek der übliche Sprecher
romenis in NV kündigt an dass der
ayatolla heute Nacht mit einer Air
France Maschine zwischen 23 Uhr und 1
Uhr morgens Frankreich in Richtung tean
verlässt zum letzten Mal ist aatomeini
zum Mittagsgebet in seine improvisierte
Moschee unter dem Zelt gegangen welche
Gedanken bewegen wohl diesen streitbaren
Kreis der nach 15jährigem Exil in sein
Heimat zurückkehrt nachdem er seinen
Todfeind den Schar vertrieben hat
das Unternehmen fliegender Teppich hat
begonnen jetzt ist es wirklich soweit
a fliegt von Paris Charles de GA nach
thean ab die Perser auf diesem Flugzeug
sind relativ wenig zahlreich dagegen die
internationale Presse stark vertreten
und das bietet wohl auch eine gewisse
Gewehr dass das Flugzeug bei der Landung
in tean nicht von der Luftabwehr
beschossen wird wir befinden uns hier in
der besetzten amerikanischen Botschaft
der Raum ist wohl die Bibliothek der
Botschaft an den Wänden stehen
Inschriften down with America nieder mit
Amerika in einer Ecke steht eine
zusammengerollte amerikanische Fahne
immer die Beziehung zwischen teiran und
Washington sind zurzeit sehr gespannt
vor allem seit der Besetzung der
amerikanischen Botschaft durch die
Studenten welches ist ih Haltung
gegenüber den Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika nach meiner Meinung sind nur die
Vereinigten Staaten Schuld an der
augenblicklichen
Situation die islamischen Völker und
unser islamisches Volk machen keine
Unterschiede zwischen Völkern sie sind
für Gerechtigkeit und nicht für
Ungerechtigkeit aber die USA wollen dass
die Ruhe im Iran nicht wiederhergestellt
wird
sie kommmen wie kein anderer Europäer
was war ein Eindruck haben sie von ihm
gewonnen ja manche sagen es war eine
mittelalterliche Gestalt meiner Ansicht
nach ist eine biblische Gestalt Prophet
des Alten Testaments gewesen sehr ein
sehr charismatisch
und es hat auch einen Vertrauensbeweis
gegeben also über meinen Freund dabei
der ein enger Verwandter von Romen war
bin ich dann aufgebeten worden in die
obere Kabine des Jumbo wo er sein Gebet
verrichtete auf dem Flug aus dem Exil
von Paris nach von Paris nach teiran und
wir wussten ja nicht ob das Flugzeug
abgeschossen würde ob er bei der Ankunft
getötet oder festgenommen wurde und da
hat dann Tabi ein gelbes K gegeben der
weiter gereicht hat
und er hat mir dann gesagt wenn wir
festgenommen oder umgebracht werden
verstecken sie es wirklich gut und wenn
nicht geben es mir zurück und da stand 2
Millionen Menschen jubelt rum so zurück
und ein paar Monate später hat wir
gesagt dass drin war es war die
Verfassung der Islamischen Republik Iran
ich bin zwei Stunden lang der Wächter
der Verfassung gewesen da erinnern sich
die Iraner heute noch
dran mit der Rückkehr komenis in den
Iran ist so etwas wie auf die Weltbühne
getreten wie der politische Islam der
die Macht
ergreift wie hat das die Welt verändert
ja das wird oft falsch dargestellt
nämlich es hat eine große Wirkung gehabt
aber vergessen wir nie nicht dass die
iranische Revolution eine schitische
Revolution war und die anderen eben die
Araber sind Sunniten und eine ein
wirklich zündenden ein übersprüngenden
Funken von der scha von Scheden auf
dieitat nicht gegeben und heute sind die
beiden Richtungen großen Richtungen des
Islam in ein eine absolute
Todfeindschaft miteinander verwickelt
die schlimmer ist als die Feindschaft
gegenüber den Christen bleiben wir kurz
noch mal beim
Iran wie sehr ist die Sorge vor der
iranischen Atombombe berechtigt also a
strebt der Iran nach einer Atombombe und
wie gefährlich wäre sie im Zweifelsfall
ja wahrscheinlich ist das so ähnlich wie
in Amerika da gibt's Leute die möchten
bombardieren me die die die wissen dass
ein Bombardement ein ein totales Schos
sein würde aber in in Iran gibt's zwei
los V den
revolutionswächtern der Garde des
Regimes GI Leute die die Bombe bauen
möchten romeni selbst war nie besonders
begeistert davon
und was würde es ändern die würden die
Idee dass die Iraner eine atombombe auf
Israel abwerfen ist völlig blözig
nämlich dann das wäre die
Selbstvernichtung des Iran nämlich
zurecht würden dann sowohl die Israeli
die auch auf ihren uboten ihre Bomben
haben und vor allem die Amerikaner
würden dann eben den Iran ausloschen
also das ist alles g dummes geredet die
Gefahr das Erkennen die Amerikaner aber
man redet ja nicht drüber es wird ja es
wird alles
vertuscht die befucht und der Amerikaner
richten sich heute schon mehr auf
Pakistan als auf den Iran spätestens
seit den Anschlägen auf die das World
Trade Center beherrscht die
Auseinandersetzung zwischen dem Westen
und dem anen Islam das Welt geschehen
wie gefährlich wie aggressiv ist der
Islam wirklich so toll ist das ja auch
nicht was ist denn passiert
gewesen schrecklich genug mit 3 mit
3000 Milionen tote GT sind auch Menschen
ja sag mal wenn man schon humanitär
redet dann auch
konsequent
und was nun seitdem hat doch keine tat
Tat gegeben diese Sache die da in Boston
stattgefunden hat war doch ein ein FL
wir haben haben die Anschläge auf die
Vorzüge in Madrid mit mehreren hundert
Toten gehabt das ist eine ganz andere
Gruppe gewesen ich war der die
Koordinierung von al-qida eine
Organisation die sehr wage war ist ja
viel später Erfolg und vor allem der
absolute Irrtum des Westens war es doch
dass 9-eleven das Werk von Afghanen
gewesen von Saudis ist gemacht
und das konnte auch nur gemacht werden
mit der Präsenz eines
gut
organisierten
Netzes in den USA n Saudis sein und OS
bin Laden ist Saudi die exemistischen
Bewegungen die auch uns berühren
inzwischen von Syrien aus nicht das
heißt Afghanistan war von Anfang an ein
Fehler weil man sich das falsche Land
ausgesucht hat absolut man hätte
natürlich hätte die dort sich Bef
ichen ausländische grüne Legion damals
hieß noch nicht
elkaidida war gar nicht bekannt bei den
Afghanen aber die Amerikaner hatten ja
eine Legion zusammengestellt mit dem
Saudis zusammen die das finanziert hab
gegen die Russen und das ist die Truppe
vonin Laden gewesen und die war von
Anfang zwar antirussisch die wollten
natürlich Russen die waren nicht
proamerikanisch ich war mit den
unterwegs und damals schon das am Anfang
des Krieges und
muss wirklich am Verstand der der
Geheimdienste zweifeln schrienen also
die Leute mit denen
ging schwierigen leländ sch Allah Akbar
gott ist groß und Amerika tot in
Amerika kämpft mit Amerikaner mit
amerikanischen geldwaffen und schreib
tot den Amerikanern aber es war einfach
so sie waren auch gegen
Amerika also ich verstehe sie so die die
CIA t eine Mitschuld am Entstehen von
von al-qida ich würde trotzdem gerne
wissen der Islam ist doch im Prinzip
auch eine Religion wie das Christentum
der nach paradiesischen Zuständen auf
auf der Erde und im Jenseits sucht wieso
kommt es dass im Namen des Islam überall
auf der Erde Menschen schreckliche
Anschläge machen in Pakistan in der
arabischen Welt in Madrid aufs World
Trade Center wie kommt
das Gott das ist eine kollektive
Hysterie schlimm genug das schlimme ist
ja das bei uns übergreift es sind ja
nicht nur die Söhne von Migranten die
inzwischen in Syrien Kämpfen auf Seiten
der Jihadisten das sind ja
deutsche konvertien die dabei sind und
die lernen dort
Krieg zu führen und die lernen auch dort
Sprengsätze herzustellen und eines Tags
kommen die nach Hause und die werden
wahrscheinlich et effizienter sein als
diese Narren und Dilettanten von der
sogenannten sauerlandbande nicht das
einzig was die ja aufgedeckt hier in
Deutschland ja die die Frage ist ja was
macht man denn jetzt die erste Antwort
des Westens der USA auf den islamischen
Terror war der Krieg gegen den Terror in
im Irak in Afghanistan wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden hab völlig völlig
falsche te mit dem Terror überhaupt
nichts zu tun gehabt also die dieser
Teil des Krieges gegen den Terror ist
völlig schief gegangen hat
ist die richtige Antwort auf islamischen
Terror ja mein Gott
die Europäer müssen erstmal lernen sich
selbst zu verteidigen wieder nicht
Europa ist einer Situation im Grunde der
be einer Hilflosigkeit ich wenn es drauf
ankommt das hat man ja in Libyen gesehen
dass die Franzosen die brittenen
bombardiert haben am fünften Tag gingen
die Bomben aus D mussen wir die
Amerikaner einspringen also sind unsere
schwierige Situation ist eben dass wir
einerseits
die amerikanische Politik in vielen
Punkten nicht bejahen können aber dass
wir in entscheidenden Punkt wieder auf
die Amerikaner angewiesen sind weil
Europa nicht verteiligungsfähig ist das
gesagt wir brauchen eine europäische
Konzentration der Kräfte im Grunde
kommen da drei drei Länder in Frage das
sogenannte Weimarer dre das wäre
Deutschland Frankreich und Polen das
daraus könnte man eine Armee schmen
warum lassen sie England außen vor gr
eng Engländer sind nach Amerika
ausgerichtet wir können auf die da auf
die eng nicht nicht zählen die eng haben
eine kleine aber vorzügliche Armee ich
habe auch mit Engel operiert in Waser
und haben mir sehr imponiert haben auch
fabelhafte spezialtrppen aber die eng
sind total auf Amerika ausgerichtet und
ichmer das Geschrei Gottes Willen wenn
die
Amerika wenn er austreten wollt dann
tretet doch aus die Engländer hätten ja
so viel Nachteil davon dass es gar nicht
machen W wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden
habe sagen sie wir die Europäer müssen
die militärische Schlagkraft erhöhen
jetzt gibt's ja große Teile der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit vielleicht
sogar die Mehrheit die sagen die
Zeitalter der kriegerischen Außenpolitik
ist doch schon längst vorbei ja die der
der konventionellen äh kriegerischen
Auseinandersetzung nicht war die die
Bundeswehr ist im Grunde nach den Rezept
angetreten als wurde sie die stoßarmeen
der Sowjetunion in der nchdeutschen
Tiefebene aufhalten ich habe mich doch
mit den Hubschrauberpiloten der Bundes
es gab leider nur ganz wenige
Hubschrauber und sagten wir haben ja
Geräte
auch auf 3000 m Höhe was hier normal ist
kommen die gar nicht richtig hoch und
Kriegen den ständigen
Sandstaub sandstom sind die überhaupt
nicht grö die waren dauernd auf einem
Boden weil sie Pannen hatten so war die
ganze ausrü die die bundesfehr ist
in in Afghanistan kaum kaum kampftuglich
gewesen ihr neuestes Buch heißt Welt aus
den Fugen und da ist mir ein Satz
aufgefallen den ich gerne zitieren
möchte die Pose eines Predigers für
Demokratie und Menschenrechte habe ich
mir nie angemasst was was bedeutet das
ja es gibt ein franzöischen
von du hum Person äh der der Freund des
Menschengeschlechts ist niemandes Freund
und ich habe also von diesen Gutmenschen
genügend rumlaufen sehen da ist viel
Eitelkeit nein was man braucht ist
Sachkenntnis
äh und un hert auch ja ist es denn nicht
die die vordränglichste Aufgabe der
deutschen Außenpolitik mein zumindest
viele dass wir z.B gegenüber Russland
dass wir z.B gegenüber China die
Einhaltung der Menschenrechte ein klagen
was muten wir uns denn da an ja die
Deutschen haben die grauhaftesten
Verbrechen begangen
die das übertrifft sches das war so ist
immer nichtind das will aus der ste kam
das das höchst zivilisierte Volk das
Volk der denk Dichter die das
angerichtet haben und die wollen jetzt
der übrigen Welt zeigen wie man die
Menschenrechte vertritt dann sagt man
natürlich ja gerade weil wir das gemacht
haben dann müssen wir doch jetzt das
Gute Beispiel geben h sollten ein
bisschen die Schnauze halten ja und die
and abgesehen davon
so perfekt ist die Achtung der
Menschenrechte von Seiten der Amerikaner
auch nicht ich rede nicht nur von abuai
dann der drohenkrieg der im Moment
geführt wird der absolut gegen jedes
Völkerrecht verstürzt was was sollte
denn dann eine kluge deutsche
Außenpolitik
leiten wir haben gemeinsame Interesse
mit
Amerika wir haben gemeinsame Interesse
mit Russland
wir sind die Russen eben bedroht durch
den Islam ich ja die haben sehr akute
akutes Gefühl dafür das gibt jetzt noch
kan
wgau
und wir
sollten nicht dauernd China als als
Feind wir sollten normale Beziehung
unterhalten auch die Chinesen haben ja
ihre Probleme jetzt mit den Uiguren also
insofern wir wir hätten die Deutschen
erstaunlicherweise sind weiterhin sehr
beliebt in der Welt
aber Sie müssen auch mal ein bisschen
Entschlossenheit zeigen und nicht immer
nur
auf diese komischen osterweiterungen da
blicken die die Moment stattfinden he
Entschlossenheit Deutschland sollte eine
aktivere Rolle in der Welt spielen auch
mit Truppen im Zweifelsfall nach Afrika
nach Mali in die Zentralafrikanische
Republik das würde sehr die muss man
sehr differenziert Hand haben die
Franzosen haben in Mali ein
hervorragenden feldsuch geführt aber
jetzt wird Zeit das Ausgehen ich war das
kann man nicht ewig bleiben und die
Zentralafrikanische Republik die ich
leider auch mal bereist schreckes Land
da hat man wird man sowieso nicht
zurechtkmen man muss sich das dann genau
überlegen und dann eben an gezielten
Punkten zuschlagen das ist ich bin auch
nicht in den in den Generalstäben der
der der mch im Moment ich weiß nur dass
was man im Moment macht im allgemeinen
falsch ist und falch weil es nicht den
deutschen Interessen dient oder falsch
weil es eine F falsche Lage Verl sich
was ja normal wäre ist in Afrika sagt
man die Afrikaner sind Leiter daund
europäische oder amerikanische Soldaten
rumlaufen zu sehen die wollen ihre
eigene eigen Konflikte mit eigenen
Kräften lösen aber sind ja nicht in der
Lage dazu ich bin ihm daravor gewesen in
diesen ganzen Gebieten und leider ist
diese Truppe die die Afrikanische Union
aufstellt fast genauso schlimm wie die
ausländischen ich habe schon
angesprochen ihr neuestes Buch heißt
Welt aus den Fugen warum ist die Welt
aus den Fugen
geraten
1us Gründen ich vor allem ist völlig
törg wir hatten ja ein einen
einigermaßen vernünftigen Zustand
erreicht nach dem Ende des Kalten
Krieges und dann hat man sich eben in
alle möglichen Abenteuer verirrt
und man hat die Übersicht verloren man
man hat nicht begriffen dass wir es
nicht mehr eine mit einer bipolaren Welt
zu tun haben das war ganz ordentlich mit
Amerikaner und Russen die die hen sich
gegen Schach und da passiert auch nicht
wir haben jetzt mit einer multipolaren
Welt zu tun
und wie sie schon sagten die Frage des
Islam wird uns noch gewaltig
beschäftigen nämlich es ist nicht nur
Syrien es ist nicht nur Irak das ist
nicht n der Iran das ist nicht nur
Jordanien morgen
oder Libyen ist ein vololler Auflösung
in Ägypten passiert da jeden Tag ein
Attentat und auch Algerien all das ist
in unserer melbaren Nachbarschaft und da
muss man eben mal eine eine große
Planung machen die kann nicht rein
national sein die müsste europäisch sein
aber fangen Sie doch mal was mit
Europäern an let ZTE Zeit von mitron und
Kohl war die deutsch-französische
militärische Zusammenarbeit enger als
sie heute ist können Sie sich eine Welt
ohne Kriege vorstellen ja ich könnte mir
eine wünschen aber es wird keine geben
es wird immer Kriege gegeben
kennen Sie
eine Epoche der der Weltgeschichte wo
keine Kriege stattgefunden
haben 70 Jahre rastloses reporterleben
quer durch die Welt gab es in all den
Jahren auch Momente wo sie so etwas wie
ein stinktnormales Familienleben
vermisst haben habe ich eigentlich nie
geführt und habe ich auch nicht ernst
auf versucht muss ich eich
sagen das war nicht schon das waren
Beruf auch nicht zu vereinbaren gewesen
sie haben mit 60 noch Mal geheiratet Eva
schollatur wo haben Sie sich dann
kennengelernt wir haben uns in
Südostasien in Laos kennengelernt kann
eigentlich bei Peter schonatur auch
nicht anders sein das muss dann
Indochina sein ja das war sehr
romantisch nicht das war so ein Stück Z
Norm und ein Stück Graham Gren bisschen
nicht romantische Angelegenheit und sie
tragen an Stelle eines Ehre Rings einen
Armreif was ist das für ein Armreif also
das ist der ist aus Laos der ist von
einem meostamm das sind die Stämme die
oben im Gebirge Leben und ich habe in
Laus gekauft und mein Mann geschenkt hat
sich sowas immer gewünscht begleiten sie
ihren Mann auf Reisen oft do ja oft oft
aber er nimmt mich nicht überall hin mit
und ehrlich gesagt will ich auch nicht
immer immer überall hin mitgehen aber
z.B jetzt hat er ja eine Reise in den
schad geplant und da würde ich gerne
mitgehen also nicht weil mich dieses
Land so reizt aber ich habe nicht so
gerne wen ganz alleine fährt wie ist das
mit mit ihren Sorgen weil es nicht
risikolos ist ja dann mache ich mir
schon Sorgen also ist z.B damals während
des Irak Kriegs sehr oft im Irak gewesen
und das hat mir nicht sehr gefallen aber
das muss mir nicht gefallen den er würde
ohneehin Reisen gibt's für Sie so etwas
wie persönliches Glück ist das Kategorie
in der sie
denken sch das ist was heißt Glück
also der General hat mal gesagt das
Glück gibt's überhaupt nicht Gott wir
haben natürlich heute eine
Zwangsvorstellung vom glücklich sein
durch die Amerikaner die per happiness
nicht wir jeder glücklich sein oder
zumindest glücklich erscheinen D machen
alle strahann also das mir nicht es gibt
schon Momente in denen man auch
glücklich ist aber sind kurz
wir kennen ihren Mann als rationalen
Erklärer der Weltpolitik kann ihr Mann
auch emotional romantisch sein ja Gott
sei
Dank das kann der sternhc nein der
Spiegel wars hat sie mal den letzten
welterklärer genannt das eigentlich ein
schöner Titel oder sehr schöner Titel
auch sehr schmeichelhaft er hat nicht
immer so positiv mich geäußert aber ich
nehme das ganz Z könnnis aber
ich ma mir auch keine Illusion über die
Dauerhaftigkeit der Auswirkung meiner
Schriften sie haben zahllose Reportagen
fürs Fernsehen gedreht über 30
Bestseller gibt es eine Kernbotschaft
etwas was sie den Menschen auf jeden
Fall mitgeben wollen ich habe nicht die
vermissenheitieren zu wollen ich will
sie informieren ich will vor allem sag
was ja sehr viel gibt es gibt ja
regelrechte Informationskampagnen die
gibt's mehr und mehr dagegen gehe ich
eins ganz Leben getan aber im Grunde bin
ich ein bisschen der einsame rufende in
der in der Wüste
geblieben das war der Dialog diesmal zum
90 Geburtstag von Peter scholatur
herzlichen Dank an sie beide
danke